the back nothing more
meeting
we did everything
the base
with us
the
to
it's a little later
and
m
frankly
question
sneeze
we
the fans
m
it's death
arleston game
the last time and
around the 28
the emir visually impaired and  well protected
lately
but basically followed by people
like that
[Music]
it's true you don't have them yet
no
[Music]
yes
[Applause]
it's wrong
it's fine
[Music]
m
the
cb
m
the people
we have a nice game
[Applause]
m
[Music]
we
[Applause]
living
welcome
how to vote
there is
I
g
this relay
[Music]
1 life
[  Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
m
look there
[Applause
] guys from the balkans
[Music]
video
gallas de fonds
[Music]
m
we
yes
why man
the good
the economy goes on
[Music]
ago  had 1
the counter
[Music]
after tomorrow
his technique
[Music]
m
it's messy
jean bart
this kind of event that everyone
talks to death and praying
it
the cx young people elsewhere
[Music]
high tech what do we do
it's  in Switzerland to lawyers
quote that they there were pensions with
a city of the aggressor deviations were
figure is reached me I have some
points of turns yes but it is only on
the live if they want to make one
consulting package in dhr
[Music]
he explained that it's because I
brought
here that's
nice
so much
the better
I'm not if you read
the bodies of ferrets a few minutes ago
[Music]
he
never
[Music]
I don't know it's in
he
[Music]
peter weir
bouffier
it's always
yeah
[Music]
and after
12 years
between mobiles
after google a bit
[Music]
so that I leave at the  comfortable it's a
coincidence that I like this site
the game
where his memory came from
[Music]
besson
he likes
the case
[Music  e]
why
the shop
[Music]
there
not at all
[Music]
and
the convoy
I would say
the game
[Music]
and
I
[Music]
when
the army
[Music]
in  waiting
yes
no
their expectations
[Music]
marion for
show will he know
[Music]
okay I don't
travel to
paris most
[Music]
no
I can only
mm
[Music]
see you at 5 p.m.  believe
republic I was tired
your calls in fact at 2 p.m. and a year
later yeah I believe that I have the south
[Music]
4th are leaving
to take a little to see
something
my bag that l  'avenue calls my sachet
in French ladji bas touched
[Music]
I want to say
since nantes ap times that I come back
although she can
nicolas
[Music]
it's not very
they haven't
I'm at the garden party on  will follow them
my opinion we put potvin
[Music]
I first chose serious time
water
[Music]
no
[Music]  ]
is this tone but not restrained which comes to
block his legs
he added
he
a man
yes that
ap
[Music]
you have played now
hello so
8 hours
inMay
I'm going to pass
they don't care
in fact
thank you
manage everywhere
[Music]
the world mecca
how
sorting out the checkout
[Music]
ok the versions
waited
and neither his family
[Music]
oh
but
I me I
before
we just saw each other well
oh
hu
c  it's good
I doubt it
neither
then
a one-armed effect the champion
[Music]
jealous
he
understands
[Music]
and he was talking about football
yes
and
I
see you
[Music]
they need
it
but
[Music]
and
[Applause]
warrior
I
he
how
ansa
[Music]
but for d
sir
it will take
June 2
[Music]
presentation
I think
I will